[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلوها
الاخضر السعوديه
في اولى مبارياته الافتتاحيه بمونديال
العالم لكره القدم
[تصفيق]
ايران توقف عشرات الاجانب على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات والامم المتحده تحذروا من ان
الوضع ده تحرجه
تركيا
وتجنب التصعيد
واشنطن تؤكد التزامها بالتعاون العسكري مع
الرياضه
مبروك السعوديه الى موضوع اخر مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات في ايران جراء مقتل محسنين على
يد الشرطه انضمت احياء جديده في طيران الى
المشهد حيث تظاهر العديد في شوارع في
شوارع مختلفه بينها بولفار فردوس وسطيه
وسعاده ابان وذلك لاول مره منذ اندلاع
التظاهرات في سبتمبر الماضي وقد نزلت
مجموعات من الايرانيين منذ فجر اليوم الى
الشوارع لدعم المدن الكرديه التي شهدت
صعيدا من قبل قوات الامن وقد ردد المحتجون
هتافات مثل الموت الديكتاتور والموت
البسيج هذا واغلقت السلطات الايرانيه
صحيفه جيهان سند الاقتصاديه بعد توجيهها
اتهامات الى قوات الامن على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات فيما ادانت وزاره الخارجيه
الكنديه تهديدات السلطات الايرانيه
للصحافيين داخل وخارجه ايران مؤكده ان
حريه التعبير هي حق اساسي من حقوق الانسان
هذا وارتفعت حصيله قتل التظاهرات في ايران
الى 416 قتيلا على الاقل بينهم 51 طفلا
وفقا منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه واشار
مدير المنظمه محمود اميري مقدم الى ان
القتل المنهجي المحتاجين مدنيين من اقليتي
الاكراد والبلوش يصل الى حد الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه وكانت المنظمه قد دعت في الاونه
الاخيره الى انشاء اليه مساءله تحت اشراف
الامم المتحده لمنع المزيد من قتل
المتظاهرين في ايران
في غضون ذلك نددت المفوضيه الساميه لحقوق
الانسان التابعه للامم المتحده بقمع
السلطات الايرانيه للاحتجاجات ووصف
المتحدث باسم المفوضيه فولكرتون الوضع في
ايران بالحرج للغايه مشيرا الى مقتل اكثر
من 300 محتج بينهم 40 طفلا على الاقل
اعلن القضاء الايرانيه اعتقال 40 اجنبيه
في الاحتجاجات التي اشعلها مقتل الشاب
امين على يد قوات الامن منذ سبتمبر الماضي
وقال المتحدث باسم السلطه القضائيه
الايرانيه مسعود ستايشي ان هذه الاعتقالات
جاءت بسبب ضلوعهم في الاحتجاجات
مع من لندن لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع البحث في الشان الايراني وجدان
عبد الرحمن استاذ وجدان اهلا وسهلا بك الى
نشاط الخامسه نسمع ادانات شاجب من قبل
الدول الاوروبيه والمنظمات الدوليه ولكن
حتى الساعه لم نلاحظ ضغطا حقيقيا او
قرارات تنفيذيه اوروبيه تشكل ضغطا على
السلطات في ايران على الاقل سحب السفراء
الغربيين لماذا
تحياتي لك استاذ طالب ولا متابعيك الكرام
وايضا الف مبروك للفريق السعودي همم طبعا
همم نحن نعرف في الدول الغربيه للاسف
الشديد انه الشركات هي من تحكم همم
وليس همم المسؤولين وانما ينقذون مطالب
تلك الشركات همم للاسف انه
الاوروبيه حتى الان لم تقوم بواجبها
الانسان فيما يتعلق بما يحدث من جرائم
كبرى في ايران وخاصه
في خلال الايام الاخيره شاهدنا بانه
النظام الايراني استخدم الغاز الكلور في
في كردستان وهمم
همم مقتل عدد كبير من الاطفال والابدياء
من خلال استخدام هذا الغاز وايضا الرصاص
الرصاص الحي همم
في هذه المناطق همم طبعا انه الدول
الغربيه قامت ببعض القرارات منها في
البرلمان البرلمان الاوروبي بعدم التعاون
مع البرلمان الايراني بعض الخطوات
السياسيه
هل هذه قرارات زاجره برايك من شانها ان
تشكل ضغطا على الحكومه الايرانيه وعلى
السلطات ام لا تعرف ايران ان هذه القرارات
يعني لا تسمن ولا تغني من جوه
صحيح استاذ طالب بانه هذه القرارات لن ترد
عن نظام الايراني وشاهدنا بانه سبق وكانت
هنالك عقوبات كبيره فرضت على النظام
الايراني دمرت الاقتصاد ولكن ما زال هذا
النظام قائما ونشهد الكبير يقمع لذلك حتى
العقوبات التي فرضتها دول الاتحاد هي
عقوبات تعتبر رمزيه ولكن لا ننسى بانه
الدول تتعامل وفقا لايضا مصالحها
الاقتصاديه وعلاقاتها السياسيه لكن ما
تقوم به الدول الغربيه
رغم هذا التصور بين الدول الغربيه لم لم
تفعل شيئا ولكن هنالك بعض التحركات همم
تقوم بها اوروبا
مزيد من التطور لكن اعتقد ان هو الاعلان
عنها في هذه
اعتقد انه ما زال مبكرا لانهم يعني
هنا التواصل الى هذه النتيجه بالفعل بانه
ليست مفارقه همم ان من يستدعي السفراء هي
الخارجيه الايرانيه يعني من يستدعي
السفراء الغربيين هي الخارجيه الايرانيه
وتسلمهم مذكرات احتجاج همم
بدعم التدخل الغربي في الشان الداخلي
الايراني اليست هذه مفارقه
لا هذا يشير الى بالفعل بان الدول الغربيه
بدات همم بالفعل تضر في الداخل الايراني
ولهذا همم النظام الايراني يقوم باستدعاء
همم السفاره الغربيه لانه يعرف تماما مدى
تاثير الغربي على الاقتصاد الايراني وايضا
تاثيره سياسي والاعلامي على الداخل همم
الايراني ولهذا يتم استدعاء همم السفاره
ولا شيء انه سيكون هناك ردت فعل مقابل هذه
التصرفات وايضا حتى الاعتقالات التي قام
بها النظام الايراني
همم
الجنسيتين الايرانيه وايضا الغربيه هو
دليل بانه النظام الايراني يحاول الضغط
على الدول الغربيه من دعم الحراك وهذا
يشير بانه
الدعم الغربي بدا يضر هذا يؤثر العلاقات
ما بين ايران بين الدول الغربي وقد نشهد
ايضا طرد السفاره وهذا محتمل ووارد جدا
استاذ الطالب
ما يجري استاذ وجدان الا يجعل من
الاستحاله على دول خمسه زائد واحد طرح
امكانيه العوده مجددا الى الاعلان النووي
للعام 2015 ام لا علاقه لهذا بذال
لا اعتقد انه الامور هي مع بعض لان هذه
الملفات هي متشابهه لان حتى في موضوع
المفاوضات وايضا ان همم
العلاقات همم ما بين ايران والدول الخمسه
زائد واحد في موضوع ملف الانسان ايضا همم
موضوع الملف انه ايضا موضوع حقوق الانسان
هو ضمن جدول المناقشات ولكن تم تاجيلها في
همم المفاوضات الجاريه في في ايضا حتى
خلال الجولات الثمانيه كان موضوع الانسان
مطروح ومن هذه همم المناقشات لكن الدول
الغربيه كانت تعتقد بانه من خلال همم عدم
طرح هذا الملف بانه ايران تتعاون معهم لكن
شاهدنا انه النظام الايراني غير متعاون في
هذا المجال لذلك اعتقد انه همم تم الطرح
موضوع ملف حقوق الانسان همم
الارتباط مباشر مع هذا خاصه بعد تداخل
ايران ايضا في موضوع اوكرانيا جاي من
الانضم البحث في الشان الايراني وجدان عبد
الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ وجدان على هذه
المشاركه
ومع تصاعد الاحتجاجات في الداخل لا تحاول
طيران لفت انظار الغرب لبرنامجها النووي
ببغيه تخفيف الضغط عليه حيث بدات تخصيب
اليورانيوم بدرجه نقاء 60% في مفاعل فورد
النووي جنوب البلاد عبر استخدام اجهزه
الطرد المركزي
وفي اكتوبر الماضي كشف تقرير سري للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ايران تمضي قدما
في توسيع انشطه التخصيب اليورانيوم في
موقعنا نووي تحت الارض
التقصيب الى درجه نقاء 60 بالمئه خطوه
فنيه تقترب بشده من مستوى انتاج اسلحه
بمستوى يبلغ 90%
ايران تمتلك حاليا ما يكفي من اليورانيوم
المخصب لاعاده معالجته وتحويله الى وقود
لتصنيع قنبله نوويه واحده على الاقل
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه
ناصر الكناني قال ان بلاده اتخذت هذه
الخطوه ردا على ما وصفه بقرار الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التي تعتقد ان
ايران زادت مخزونها من اليورانيوم عالي
التخصص
احتجاج
يتعظم المد الثوري ضد النظام الايراني
يتصاعد هدير الاصوات الغاضبه ويعلوا الضغط
الدولي الرافض لقمع المتظاهرين ليزداد
الخناق يوما بعد يوم فيما يبحث النظام عن
مخرج او كل مفر من ازماته الداخليه
الخارقه تلك
هنا تطل ورقه التصعيد النووي املا في صرف
او تحويل الانذار عما يدور داخليا تصعيد
يقابله الغرب برؤيه مواكبه لمجريات
التضارات الشعبيه تلك المانيا تتفق مع
امريكا بشان التركيز على ملف حقوق الانسان
بدلا من الملف النووي لكن طهران ومع
ارتفاع حده الغضب الداخلي ترفع مستوى
تخصيب اليورانيوم في منشاه فورد بنسبه 60%
كما تدشن سلسلتين من اجهزه الطرد المركزي
وهو اذا التصعيد النووي لكن ليس ذلك فحسب
بل ورقه الاخرى تلقي بها ايران صناعه
لاحداث في موازات ما يحدث من تظاهرات لا
تهدى
الاعتقالات حيث اعتقل النظام 40 اجنبيا
دون الكشف عن جنسياتهم متهما اياهم
بالضلوع في الاحتجاجات التي اشعلها مقتل
مهس اميلي دون تقديم ادله عن ذلك الاتهام
اوراق متعدده ترمي بها طهران وبكل ثقلها
مع التعمق ازماتها الداخليه
واتساع دائره التظاهرات المناهضه للنظام
الشوط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
اوكرانيا تؤكد ان كل محطات الطاقه تعرضت
للقصف الروسي وان الدمار باتهالا
اهلا بكم جديد قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الى تركيا ستشن قريبا عمليه بريه
في سوريا ضد مقاتلين اكراد بعد غارات جويه
شنتها انقره على الشمال السوري قبل ذلك
استهدفت مسيره تركيه قاعده مشتركه للتحالف
الدولي بقياده واشنطن والقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الشماليه
وما تصاحب الهجمات التركيه على طول الحدود
السوريه والتي جاءت اخرها بعد تصريحات
الرئيس اردوغان باقتراب عمليه بريه ضد
الاكراد دعت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه الى
وقف التصعيد التركي ضدها حيث عبرت عن
املها في دور يمكن ان تلعبه واشنطن و
موسكو وفقا ما ذكره قائدها العام مظلوم
عبدي
قالت عبر وزاره الخارجيتها ان الولايات
المتحده تعارض اي تحرك عسكري يزعزع
استقرار الوضع في سوريا بعد سلسله الهجمات
الانتقاميه من قبل تركيا اما الجانب
التركي فقال عبر وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي
اكا ان العمليه العسكريه بشمال سوريا
والعراق هي الاكبر والاشمل والاكثر فاعليه
ضد المسلحين
داعيا واشنطن الى وقف دعمها لحزب العمال
الكردستاني والوحدات الكردي
هذا وصلنا الحرس الثوري الايراني جوله
جديده من الهجمات باستخدام المسيارات
والصواريخ على محيط الكركوك شمالي العراق
ضد ما وصفتها طهران بالجماعات الارهابيه
وافاد مسؤول عسكري كرديه عراقي ان الضربات
استهدفت حزب الحريه الايرانيه لكردستانيه
بالقرب من كردستان العراق
وفي وقت سابق اليوم اكد رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني ورئيسه اقليم
كردستان بارزاني اكدال التعاون من اجل حفظ
سياده العراق والعمل على منع استخدام
اراضيه للهجوم على دول الجوع وذلك في ظل
هجمات تركيا وايرانيه على مواقع في شمالي
البلاد
من جانبها قالت الممثله الخاصه للامين
العام للامم المتحده في العراق
انه لا يمكن التسامح مع الهجمات الايرانيه
المتكرره على الاراضي العراقيه واضافت
نسخه ان على العراق التصرف بشكل موحد من
اجل عدم السماح بالمزيد من الصراط
معي من الحدود العراقيه التركيه الان براس
العربيه احمد الحمداني احمد اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد الميداني من عندك وهل على
العراق تحديدا اقليم كردستان العراق ان
يتحضر للاسوء في الايام المقبله
اهلا طالب طبعا
الهجوم الجديد الذي استهدف مواقع للمعارضه
الايرانيه في الاماكن القريبه من اربيل
عاصمه تقليل كردستان وهي اولتون كوبري هذه
المنطقه هي بلده تتبع الى اداريا الى
محافظه كركوك ولكن قسم كبير منها يقع في
مناطق المتنازع عليها ما بين اربيل
وبغداد وهذا طبعا
بحسب ما شاهدناه وتابعناه ومصادرنا تقول
ان طائرات مسيره مفخخه وصواريخ هي التي
استهدفت مقرات الحريه هذا الحزب الذي
المعارض لطيران بالنسبه
لكردستان ربما صحيح كلامك ربما همم
تتوقعوا كون ان هناك حدود من الحرس الثوري
الايراني على الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
بالقرب واجد في هذه المناطق وهذه المناطق
طبعا هي مناطق شومان وسيده كان وايضا
مناطق برادوس ليله القريبه من حدود
وتسعى او يسعى حرس الثوري الايراني الى
الى تطبيق الى كردستان ايران من جهه
العراق في العمق العراقي على بوفق المصادر
وعزل كردستان ايران عن كردستان العراق لما
تعتقده طيران بان كردستان العراق له دور
كبير في دفع الاحتجاجات والتصعيد في
كردستان ايران وفي مناطق اخرى في ايران
طيب احمد هذا من الجانب الايراني ماذا عن
الجانب التركي بتعرف في يعني كذلك في
تصريحات وتهديدات متزايده وفي معلومات على
انه انقره تتهيا لعمليه عسكريه واسعه
النطاق وان كانت ستركز على الشمال السوري
ولكن ستطالب مناطق همم كردستان همم
حديث في كردستان العراق حيث انت متواجد
يدور عن تواكل محدود ام عن عمليه عسكريه
واسعه النطاق نتكلم عن عمليه تركيه
واقعها الطالب واقعه حال ان تركيا لديها
39 الى 42 قاعده ونقطه عسكريه فوق قمم
جبال العراق في محافظات في محافظه دهوك
ولديها قاعده عسكريه في السيليكون في
الشمال الشرقي من الموصل
بالتالي هذه تعتبر قوات بريه اما التحرك
البري المقصود هنا وايضا هم عزلوا عزلوا
همم مناطق شاسعه من الاراضي
واقتطاعوها من العراق وحولها الى مناطق
صراع تحت نيران قناصتهم واصلاحتهم
المختلفه وطائراتهم ومسائراتهم وبالتالي
هم يتواجدون وقع على الاراضي العراقيه
والله والقوات البريه ان تحركت فانها
تتحرك في هذه المواقع المعروفه ولكن هناك
منطقه مرشحه وهي الجبال قنديل قنديل
القريبه من مكان هي حدوديه 12 كيلو متر
على الحدود العراقيه ربما تصلها تصلها
طبعا تركيا في حمام البريه ولكن هذه
المنطقه بصراحه
اين تقف قوات البشمركه من كل ما يجري
البيشمركه الكرديه ل- ل- اا ليس من
واجباتها طالب حفظ الحدود العراقيه مع دول
الجوار هذا القرار وفق الدستور العراقي او
هذا المهمه نقطه بحرس الحدود العراقي
التابع لوزاره الداخليه الاتحاديه هنا في
اقليم كردستان يوجد لواء او اكثر من لواء
يتبع الى بغداد صحيحه وما هو من كردستان
لكنه يتبع اداريا وعسكريا وماليا الى
بغداد يتوزع على طول شريط الحدود لكن هل
هو يمسك الحدود الجواب لا هناك نصف الحدود
هي فارغه امنيا تركيا ليس فيها ولا جندي
وطبعا بحسب ما شاهدت ولا جد عراقي على
الحدود العراقيه الدوليه الدوليه هنا طالب
كون ان الحرس الحدود العراقي قد اختلق
حدود جديده وانتشر اليها ولكنها في العمر
عراقي ساكتفي بهذا القدر من الحدود
العراقيه الترك ايام مراسل العربيه احمد
الحمداني شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المتابعه
قال قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
مايكل كورولا ان واشنطن ملتزمه بمكافحه
التهديد الحوثي واشار كورولا في تصريحات
لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط الى ان بلاده ونجح حد
بالتعاون مع السعوديه في منع دخول متفجرات
للمنطقه من ايران واعتبر المسؤول
الامريكيه التعاون العسكري مع السعوديه
حتميا لامن واستقرار المنطقه واكد قال
الله ان ايران هي اللاعب الاساسي المزعزع
للاستقرار في المنطقه وان النظام في ايران
يقدم الاسلحه والمال والدعم والكلاله
الملك
قبل ذلك اكد مبعوث الامم المتحده الخاص
الى اليمن هاشم ريدمبرج الالتزام بالعمل
على اعاده الحوثيين لمسار السلام والتخلي
عن خيار الحرب الذي يستمر في جلب المزيد
من الازمات على حد تعبير
مع مندوب اليمن لدى الامم المتحده عبد
الله السعدي الذي شدد على تمسك الحكومه
اليمنيه بخيار السلام رغم الانتهاكات
الحوثيه بحسب وكاله الانباء اليمن واكد
السعدي حرص مجلس القياده الرئاسي والحكومه
اليمنيه على دعم جهود المبعوث الاممي رغم
التعنت الذي يبديه الحوثيون داعيا الى
الضغط على الحوثيين لوقتها اجماتهم على
المنشات الاقتصاديه والبناء التحتيه
في الاخبار المدنيه في اوكرانيا قالت
السلطات هناك
كهربائيه تعرضت للقصف الروسي وان الدمار
هائل جدا
العربيه باستمرار القصف على احياء بمدينه
دونتس ما ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء والماء
بشكل كامل عن بعض البلده في المقابل قصفت
القوات الروسيه مراكز الجيش الاوكراني
حيث مدينه
السلطات سلمت الجانب الاوكراني صواريخ
برمسون 2 عاليه الدقه حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه في وقت السابق انها
ستسلم قريبا نحو الف صاروخ مضاد للطائرات
الى اوكرانيا واشارت لندن
اوكرانيا
مع صواريخ قادره على اسقاط اهداف من الجو
من بينها الطائرات المسيره وصواريخ روس
هذا ما قال المتحدث باسم الكريم ديمتر
بيسكوب انه يجب مطالبته اوكرانيا بسحب ما
وصفها باسلحتها الثقيله من المنطقه
المحيطه بمحطه زفروجا للطاقه النوويه
اطالب باسكوف بوقف ما تقول موسكو انه قصف
اوكراني للمحطه الاكبر في اوروبا
وتتبادل مشكل المحطه قبل ذلك دعى رئيس
الاوكراني اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي الى
ضواني الحمايه من التخريب الروسي للمنشات
النوويه حسب تعبير
مع مين خرسان الان مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد
الميداني اخر اخبار المعارك وهل التيار
الكهربائي مقطوع تماما عن احياء خرسون ام
لا يوجد تيار كهربائي
نعم تحياتي في الحقيقه كرسون مقطوعه عنها
التيار الكهربائي تماما لا يوجد كهرباء في
المدينه الا عن طريق المولدات كما تشاهد
هنا هذا المولد هو يغذي برج همم شبكه همم
شبكه الاتصالات الذي اا يعني فقط يغذي هذه
المنطقه هنا همم يعني لا توجد شبكه
اتصالات الا في هذه الساحه لذلك ياتي
المواطنين الى هذه الساحه هناك ما تشاهد
هذه الخيام المنصوبه هي مزوده بمولد
للكهرباء كذلك بتدفئه وياتي اليها
المواطنين في خرسان لشحن همم هواتفهم
السياره وايضا ل همم
الشواحن التي يمكن استخدامها فيما بعد في
المنازل في الليل ل- اا ولو اضاءه قليله
يعني او اناره بسيطه ايضا من هذا الاتجاه
اذا كانت يعني الكاميرا قادره على ان همم
توصل الصوره هنالك عدد وتجمع كبير من
المواطنين همم الذين طوال اليوم طوال
وجودنا هنا هم ياتون الى هنا للحصول على
الطعام الجاهز ذلك نسبه لانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في المنازل لا توجد كهرباء لا
يوجد ايضا مياه لا يستطيع المواطنين ان
يطبخوا في منازلهم ايضا المحلات البقاله
مغلقه تماما لا يوجد مواد تموينيه فتح
متجر وحيد من اتي به في يومين الماضيين
وكذلك وعد عمده المدينه انه في الايام
القليله القادمه سوف تبدا محلات البقاله
والمتاجر وان تفتح ابوابها شيئا فشيئا
تاتي الى المدينه فقط
المساعدات الانسانيه قبل قليل شاهدنا هنا
همم قافله من المساعدات اتت من اوديسك
كذلك لايف ارسلت المساعدات ارسلت
المساعدات لذلك يعيش المواطنين على هذا
الوضع طبعا لا يوجد كهرباء القصف متواصل
في المدينه همم بينما نتحدث الان انا اصبح
اصوات الانف اسمع كذلك اصوات اطلاق او
القذائف التي تخرج من الجانب الاوكراني
الى الضفه الاخرى التي يسيطر عليها الروس
القتال هنا في منطقه قريبه جدا من المدينه
ما زال القتال يدور القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه بمجرد ان فرغت من استعانه
السيطره على المدينه باشرت في عمليه تعزيز
الدفاعات للمدينه وكذلك ايضا في محاوله
الوصول الى الضفه الاخرى لمواصله الهجوم
كما ترى نحن الان داخل الخيمه المواطنين
يشحنون هواتفهم النقاله هنا ايضا همم
يتمتعون بالتدفئه التي لا يجدونها في
منازلهم الاغلبيه العظمى من الذين بقوا في
المدينه هم من كبار السن همم لذلك الوضع
هنا ماساوي الوضع صعب جدا ايضا همم المكان
الاخر الذي يمكن للمواطنين ان يلجاوا اليه
هو محطه القطار ايضا يلجا المواطنين الى
محطه القطار التدفئه وايضا
الشحن الهواتف وايضا
سؤال متصل ولكن ميدانيا يعني في الاجازه
الصحفي اليومي لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه ناطق
باسم وزاره الدفاع اكد ان القوات الروسيه
كبدت اليوم القوات الاوكرانيه في خرسان
خسائر فادحه وانها شنت عده هجمات واوقعت
فيهم خسائر فاتحه هذه المعلومات
عن اي عمليه تمت همم عبور ضفه النهر الى
الضفه اليسرى وان هنالك اي خسائر وقعت بين
صفوف القوات الاخرانيه لكنني بشكل عام
يمكنني ان اقول ان عمليه محاوله عبور
الضفه الى الضفه الاخرى ومواصله الهجوم
المضاد لاستعاده السيطره على ما تبقى من
مقاطعه اخر صور هو مستمر بشكل يومي اليوم
الى عمده المدينه هنا وقال لي اننا مازلنا
نواصل التقدم لاستعاده كامل اراضي هذه
المقاطعه يعني اذا كان لديك وقت يمكن
التحدث القتال في الشرق
لاحقه ولكن نحن واياك في هذه الصور يعني
المشهد اقل ما يقال عنه ماساويه يعني مع
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وانعدام التدف
على كل شكرا لمراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
كان معي من خرسون لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا
ينضم الى همم عبر الهاتف من الكلاب اوراق
رمضان وهو رئيس مركز الاوراس للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه همم سيد اوراد انطلاقا من
هذه المشاهد التي نراها واياك على الشاشه
يعني كما قلت اقل ما يقال عنها انها
ماساويه السؤال ما هي خيارات كيف وبدائلها
للانقطاع التام للتيار الكهربائي لانه
كتابات ترى المعلومات بان موسكو ستجعل كل
محطات الطاقه الاوكرانيه تخرج عن العمل
التي اتواجد فيها واا هذا الانقطاع اصبح
يعني سلاح تستعمله روسيا بقتل التحتيه من
اجل التقليد من التواصل من همم تتنقل
المعدات الاخرانيه استعمال القطار
الكهربائي لان شبكه ال- السكه الحديديه
الاوكرانيه كلها تقريبا تعتمد على التيار
الكهربائي هي سياسه معتمده من اجل اشلال
كل المنظومه الاقتصاديه
وجعل الحكومه غير قادره يعني رقص الحكومه
الاوكرانيه في مشاكل لها بدايه وليس لها
نهايه ذات اقتصادي اجتماعي انساني
والمساله يعني همم هي جريمه انسانيه يعني
عندما تقصد بنا تحتيها اجتماعيه حيويه
وتستهدف حياه المواطن الاعزل هذا يعني
روسيا تريد ان تكبد الخسائر ليس على
الجبهات ولكن تريد ان تاتي من الاخير يعني
تريد ما يعرف بمنطقه التغذيه التغذيه
الحاويه للجبهات القتال هذا هو الشيء الذي
تريده موسكو وكذلك قطع الامدادات
اللوجستيه التي تاتي من الغرب من الدعم
بالسلاح والذخيره ولذلك فان روسيا اظن
للاسف الشديد ان الفطوات
يعني طب ولكن ما هي مسؤوليه السلطات
الاوكرانيه في تامين بدائل يعني الحرب لم
تبدا بالامس همم صار لها اكثر من سته اشهر
همم وكان دائما ال ال كان المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون يقولون انهم تحضر لشتاء قارس
ولكن ما نشاهده يعني همم الصوره مختلفه
يعني هذه المشادات التي شهدها على الشاشه
حقيقه ان الصواريخ التي تقصف هي تقصف بشده
والبنت تحتيه الاوكرانيه يعني شيدت ليست
بيومين شديده من العهد السوفياتي لحقيقه
ان السوريات اللي عندما قاموا بانشاء
البنيه التحتيه الطاقويه لجمهوريه
اوكرانيا كانت السيناريو الحرب النوويه مع
حلف الناتو يعني موجود بذلك بفضل
القدره المنشات الاخرانيه على تحمل هذا
الضغط بالقصف هو الذي يمدد ويجعل همم عامل
يعني الانقطاع ليس بتلك الكاريثه ولذلك
رغم ذلك فان الدوله الاخرانيه تحاول جاهدا
لاصلاح ما لديها من قوه وقدره لهذه
المنشات وخاصه ما يعرف
بالمولدات والمحولات الكهربائيه
والان الاتحاد الاوروبي يقدم دعما يعني
بالمال وكذلك بالعتاد يعني مولدات
كهربائيه اصبحت تاتي من الغرب الى ال-
اوكراني وخاصه من اجل الحفاظ على ما يعرف
البنت التحتيه الحرجه يعني ما يخص ضغط
المياه وكذلك الامور التي تخص بالتدفئه
الامور التي تخص بعمل المنشات الحكومه
بالخدمات المرتبطه بالانترنت والمرتبطه
بالخدمات التي تعتبر يعني خارج بدون هاتف
الاقتصاد ولذلك في الاتحاد الاوروبي يقدم
هذا الدعم ولكن هل الد سنكتفي بهذا القدر
عبر الهاتف من كيب اورانج رمضان رئيس مركز
اوراس للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا
النشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
كوريا الشماليه تحذر واشنطن من ازمات اكبر
كل ما اصرت على سياستها العداد
اهلا بكم جديد زارت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
كمال هارس الجزيره بالاوان الفلبينيه
والتي تؤكد الصين حقيتها بها لاظهار دعمها
لحليف الولايات المتحده ومواجهه النفود
الصينيه المتزايد في تلك المنطقه وتظهر
الزياره التزام الولايات المتحده بالوقوف
الى جانب الفلبين في بحر الصين الجنوبي
وتعتبر هاريس اعلى مسؤوله امريكيه تزور
الجزيره الاقرب الى ارخبيل سبراتلي الواقع
في بحر الصين الجنوبيه الذي تتنازل بكين
اسياد عليه مع جيرانها
من جانبها قالت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
كمالها رزق خلال زيارته الى جزيره بالوان
ان النظام الدولي حينما يتعرض للتهديد في
مكان الماء فانه يكون مهددا في كل مكان
نشرتان الى ضروره الدفاع عن احترام
السياده ووحده الاراضي والتجاره والحل
السلميذان
وشركائنا ضد السلوك غير القانوني وغير
المسؤوله
في كل مكان يجب ان نتمسك بالقواعد
والمعايير الدوليه يجب ان ندافع عن مبادئا
مثل احترام السياده ووحده الاراضي
والتجاره المشروعه دون والحل السلمي
للنزاعات وحريه الملاحه والتحليق في بحر
السنه الجنوبيه وفي جميع انحاء المحيطين
الهندي
تحسين الاتصالات اثناء الاسماء وذلك خلال
اجتماع مع نظيره الصيني
وابدا اوستنققه بشان ما اعتبره سلوكارا
بشكل متزايد للطائرات العسكريه الصينيه
وقد وصف البنتاجون في بيان الله الذي
استمر 90 دقيقه بانه مثمر ومهني وهو اول
اجتماع من نوعه رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي
في اغسطس والتي اثارت غضب الصين التي
تعتبر الجزيره جزءا من اراضيه
من جانبه قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه ان الوزير الصيني ونظيره
الامريكي اتفقاه على تبني سياسه منطقيه
وعمليه لتعامل الجيشين بشكل مناسب مع
الخلافات وتعزيز اداره الازمات للحفاظ على
استقرار علاقتهما بشكل عام
لا تتحمل الصين اي مسؤوليه عن الوضع
الحالي للعلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه السبب
الرئيسي لذلك هو ان الولايات المتحده
اصدرت حكما استراتيجيا
الصين صادقه في تطوير العلاقه الثنائيه
لكن الفرضيه الاساسيه هي ان الولايات
المتحده يجب ان تفعل ما تقوله وتفي
بوعودها وتنفذ التوافق الذي توصل اليه
رئيس الدولتين وتحترم بجديه مصالح الصين
الاساسيه والاهتمامات الرئيسيه وتتبنى
سياسات الحوار العقلانيه والبراغماتيه
للقضاء بشكل فعال على الاسباب الجذريه
للتهديدات
في سياق اخر انتقدت كيم يونج شقيقه زعيم
كوريا الشماليه جلسه مجلس الامن التي خصصت
لمناقشه التجارب الصاروخيه التي تجريها
بيومجان وقالت في بيان النشرته وكالات
الانباء المركزيه ان المجلس ابهر معايره
مزدوجه بشان تطوير الاسلحه وتدخلات سياسيه
خطيره وغير مقبوله واضافت ان الولايات
المتحده ستواجه ازمات اكبر كلما اصرت على
سياستها العدائيه وان كوريا الشماليه
ستتخذ اجراءات قويه وقاسيه ضد كل من ينتهي
سياده يوميا
مليارات سام بانكمان والعملات المشفره
التي جعلته اسطوره ماليه كانت حديثا الناس
لحيني خسارتها باكملها فتحولت الانظار الى
كواليس الحياه اليوميه لرئيس شركه اف تي
اكس حيث اظهرت صور نشرتها صحيفه
غارق بمستنقع المخدرات وصحب الحفلات حيث
يتجاهل بشكل تام انهيار شركه
مليارات واسطوره العملات المشفره سان بانك
منفرايد هوت خلال شهر نوفمبر وتبخرت كما
تبخرت الامل بتحوله الى نسخه التشفير من
عملاق القطاع المالي جون بيربونت مورجان
الذي اسس اكبر بنك امريكا
فرائسه بورصه العملات المشفره المنهاره اف
تي اكس الذي خسر نحو 15 مليار دولار في
يوم واحد اي نحو 94% من قيمه ثروته يهوي
هو الاخر في مستنقع الفوضى وفقا نيويورك
بوست صور متعدده نشرتها الصحيفه الامريكيه
تظهر ضياع الملياردير المفلس واصدقائه
التسعه في رفاهيه المنتجه الذي يمتلكه في
جزر البهاما ما بين ملاعب الجولف وليقوت
الفارهه هيئه صاخبه بكل المقاييس احتيالا
ومخدرات واقامه حفله بشكل دوري وما يتضمنه
ذلك من افعال فاضحه وفقا نيويورك بوست
واضافت انا باك مان يتناول المخدرا يسمى
امسا وهو احد مشتقات المثل فيتامينات
المستخدم لعلاج مرضى الباركنسون لافته الى
معاناته من اثار جانبيه جره تناول هذا
المخدر
قيمه اصولهم خفضت الى صفر لتصف حاله
بانكمن باحدى اكبر حوادث تدمير الثروه في
التاريخ وفقا لهم برجر لكن في ما سفينته
تغرق يعيش الشاب الثلاثيني في حاله انكار
تام لما يجري ولم يتوقف عن ممارسه العاب
الفيديو بحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه
اظهرت الصور اضرارا جسيمه لحقت بمنازل
ومطاعم ومتاجر في اندونيسيا افرازات قوي
ضرب جزيره جاوه وادى الى مقتل اكثر من
طرقات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]
وبركاته
[تصفيق]